كيمياء وغير مخفيه تجمع الرياض وبكين سرعت
عجله التعاون العسكري والاقتصادي التي
سبقت التقطير السياسيه الكامله بينهما
تركيبه العلاقه بين البلدين تعود جزئيتها
لمجموعه من الدوافع المتبادله فاولويات
العلاقه مع الشريك الصينيه تتمثل بالتعاون
غير المشروط الغياب اي شروط صينيه في
الانفتاح على مزيد من افاق التعاون بين
الجانبين
المملكه على الصين ليستثناء بل يدخل ضمن
سياسه التوسع شرقا واستراتيجيه تعدد
البدائل والتحالفات وان كان بمستويات
متفاوته الا ان الصين استحوذت على الحصه
الكبرى لامكانياتها الاقتصاديه وموقعها
بمجلس الامن سياسه تبعت برسائل لبعض حلفاء
المملكه بعدم
رهن المصالح لخيارات دوله محدده مهما
كانتها
ودمنه مزايا التعاون تدخل السوق الصينيه
المتعطشه للنفط ومصادر الطاقه في الصين
التي تعد رابع منتجا للنفط في العالم
تعتمد على الاستيراد كذلك بسبب ارتفاع
الطلب اكثر من الانتاج المحليه وهنا تاتي
محاوله ابعاد الصين عن ايران او على الاقل
اضعاف علاقتها بها وبالتالي تقليل الحاجه
الصينيه للنفت الايراني وزياده ضغط
العقوبات على طهران من جهتها تستقطب
السعوديه الاهتمام الصيني من منطلق موقعها
بالمنطقه العربي
ومركزيه قرارها فالتعاون مع المملكه يطفي
مشروعيه على سياسه الصين الخارجيه وثقالها
بالمنطقه وما وزين القوه الدوليه كما يخلق
فرصا لتحسين صورتها بالعالم العربي
تعاون يصب ايضا في زاويه مستلزمات مشروعها
لاستراتيجي المتمثل بطريق الحرير بحكم
الموقع الجغرافي للسعوديه
وامكانياتها الم اديه